a lot of you asking me whether i think
that college is necessary for success in
this world well my answer is
it depends okay it depends um
first of all um
what are the pulls what are your
priorities and so on experimentation by
and large
if you use college as an opportunity to
explore and you also develop
relationships and you get a whole lot
out of college that's better than the
alternatives at the time then it's the
better path if on the other hand you go
into the real world and you mess around
with that and you're going to learn a
lot more and then you can come back and
you can do college later it's a choice
so you have to find out what are your
circumstances don't let convention stand
in the way right let the exploration of
what are your best alternatives at that
time and then go explore
life is not a straight linear journey
you know it is a it is a path and so
that experimentation just as long as you
know that you're moving forward that's
what you have to go after